Oh baby power
he's on fire yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I know it was a
girlfriend
oh [ __ ] I didn't think he was going to
do that huh he's so annoying what why
doesn't he go away yeah I guess so I
guess we got to go no-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o
wait Oh hex good maybe I can lock him
okay I think he's gone though he's not
gone he is not gone he is not gonna he's
not gonna he's not yeah no one is here
no one is here
oh wait wait wait wait wait this failed
the last time Oh Oh fine buzzer door
closes ah goes out back oh okay
closer haha no no no no no no no back by
five by five by five
how's it going bros and bronies my name
is PewDiePie hope you enjoyed this video
if you did feel free to thumb it up and
add it to your favorites I'm sure a lot
of people are confused why this is on my
channel all of a sudden and to be honest
I'm confused as well I mean my machinima
video of this used to have like 350,000
views and for whatever reason they set
it on private along with a lot of other
machinima pulls I really I really don't
know why they would do that but they do
what they want I guess anyway a lot of
you wanted to still see the video so I
thought I'd have floated on my channel
so anyway